welcome to this video play texture from
the US okay let's do a fun thing
transpose to them Smith [ __ ] and they
haven't played this for for a long while
I experimented a bit with it after I got
this book going to national master mark
SML long time and more often hmm okay so
he's going for slightly offbeat slightly
offbeat line here yeah okay let's let's
adjust and you need to make it up as I
go I don't don't know anything politics
is useless no Texas just okay check so I
probably let's give this check Bishop
takes Bishop d7 I go to c4 and keep the
pawn yeah this looks nice looks like a
decent position to prevent Bishop g4
yes yeah what should I do there should
be three my play 95 a bit uncomfortable
just retreat it yeah maybe it's not bad
as the left the d5 Polly just completing
development now Bishop maybe Bishop e3
to d4 and I can't play Bishop at five
active aging the piece ok let's go here
Queen d2 Bishop h6 yeah p 6 is not not
so clear what this is doing ok once the
go to d6 but it really weakens the light
squares let's see let's check what is
doing now my intention was to play
Bishop f4 but this is not really helping
it just goes to the six if we should be
6 special a6 really was a stupid move
even I'd be five is not possible
hmm can i play d6 maybe try to justify
this the only way to to try to justify
this continuation and now I take t6 this
is easy Bishop takes 95 was my idea
which is not completely off but not
quite sure that it really was working
now I'm just a piece of okay guy is
threatening on c3 but I guess I should
just just go for further for the
activity of the rocks if I play that is
going probably probably require group
before
yeah I'm many plate didn't play well but
quickly I'm he's got more than three
minutes left so we continues for a while
we are not much to comment I mean you
just continues with lots of material
missing check check check guides doctor
not particularly complicated yes
actually one benefit of increment time
controls that quite often people stop
playing on this kind of this kind of
stuff so you can actually start a new
game that is that is really interesting
okay it's also interesting that I tried
to play in the legal move okay that one
on I can just push the apron whatever
and install it i've got almost a minute
left it's not it's not chatting like no
time at all okay black resigns yeah I
think I really I really underestimated
group c seven the only way to really
justify all this I mean okay even a move
like that let's say Bishop takes be
seven witches bit davidian logical still
leads to a pretty good position as the
spawn is week I have those ideas it's
just quite comfortable but you know this
is an interesting with the idea was
after Knight takes bishop takes Bishop
takes Knight d5 and I thought this is an
interesting position you can play that
but this looks somewhat animal yes the
comp actually gives a look you oops like
screwed up the calling area I'm sorry
the comp actually gives route 81
intending to take probably and then look
II ate midnight before with a draw
that's strange yeah well whatever
everything's better than what he did
just giving away the night and then it's
just gone played that instantly so on
after that it was really easy I'd like
to quickly check the opening and I don't
have a database already here to check
Knight f6 is an interesting move
it's knowing that this is quite
promising for white as I have a quick
Knight c3 available light f6 you're
interesting check now but this is
probably at least in a good solution
keeping this pawn and in this kind of
configuration this is really a strength
that limits black's pieces so is this
probably a good way to play alright
thanks for watching